if you're a god of war fan now may be
the time to pick yourself up a ps4 since
the system is about to get a remastered
edition of God of War 3 sony revealed
the game during a sony Santa Monica live
stream event the updated version of the
2010 ps3 game is going to have 1080p
graphics and Sony have also said they
hope to have it running at 60 frames per
second the dad showed a trailer at the
event as well as a bunch of
never-before-seen concept art you'll get
to see Kratos being an absolute bad ass
again come July 14 for 40 bucks but for
now you can enjoy to action-packed
minutes of the godslayer on gamespot the
remastered edition will also feature a
photo mode similar to the one seen in
infamous second son and the Last of Us
remastered so if you've been dying to
Instagram filter the hell out of your
crazy God of War antics that's the thing
you can do let me know down in the
comments it's this as a remaster you
want to get your hands on we'll be
keeping you updated on all the God of
War goodness on game slots so stay tuned